um let's you know last week we tried to
check in with eric from cancun
and he wasn't there so i'm going to try
once more eric from cancun can you hear
me
david it's sunny right now
um the thing i want to tell you last
week is what do you think of traditions
what do i think of traditions i am not
in favor of traditions only for
tradition's sake
i don't find virtue in traditions in
principle but i have no problem with
specific traditions that are meaningful
to people
that's exactly what i want to tell you
because traditions are too
the people that did things for us to
celebrate to improve our lives
and i still like traditions
it's like giving gifts and birthdays in
valentine's in holiday winters
then
i think that conservatives would be very
upset or worried that liberal is going
to get rid of those traditions but i
think that we're not really getting rid
of them only changing the way we do for
example in halloween i make cosmetics
for team fortress 2
and i think we should rethink about some
traditions like forcing a woman to stay
in the kitchen ignoring the opinion of
children and killing animals who pretend
to be brave and strong instead of taming
the beast like a real man also like
lieutenant dan want to die in vietnam
because his ancestors died in other wars
if you saw forrest gump
yes be a fantastic movie
and let me remember what the other thing
i was going to say oh i remember now
if you saw
you should remember just you see fiddle
in the roof the first song is called
tradition and there's a farmer called
tavian he says that in anatepca they
have traditions of how to pray how to
sleep how to eat to wear their molka to
pray to god and here's the most
important part he says when he is going
to tell us how this tradition started he
says
but it's a tradition and thanks to their
traditions they know what god expect
them to do
well eric you know you've touched in
such a short amount of time on the
weather religion philosophy
film
i can't thank you enough for the
wide-ranging phone call
i want to tell only two things before we
caught
and
oh my goodness
so the comments about our calls and they
say i have a cartoonish voice maybe if i
do my impersonation of mario like it's
me mario
can anyone tell nintendo to give this
beautiful caller shot and to work as a
new voice actor
eric from cancun thank you so much for
the call you've said it all and on that
note we're gonna have to go